hi good night everybody last night  Democrat John Federman faced off with  Republican Dr Oz in the first and only  debate for one of the most important  Senate races in the country and things  did not go great for John Federman as  lieutenant governor you're running for a  seat that could decide the balance of  power in Washington what qualifies you  to be a U.S senator you have 60 Seconds  hi good night everybody  I'm running to serve Pennsylvania he's  running to use Pennsylvania not a great  way to start and fetterman's performance  only went downhill from there I'm  Michael Knowles this is the Michael  Knowles show good night